tessa it's so wonderful to hang out with
you right now yeah thanks for having me
you know i i love this film it is
finally it's nice to see a romantic film
with incredible sultry music and
it makes you think about the music that
gets you in the mood what's that one
particular song that gets you
in that lit uh well
i don't know what mood you're referring
to
romance uh nancy wilson is a big
you know thing sort of in this
film and i love a nancy wilson song
called how glad i am
um so i played that a lot on set uh and
music's a big part of your life and i
love the fact that you created music for
creed
was that something you wanted to try for
this film or going forward
what are you doing in terms of your
music career
i didn't want to do it in this film no
because it wasn't really appropriate i
feel really lucky that i've gotten to
make some music and creed and we're
going to make another creed
soon so i'll have the opportunity to
make some more music as bianca
no way will you be writing as well
i will be yeah i've written on on all of
the creed's previous and i'll do it
again for this
for this next iteration which is
exciting um did you get a chance to
actually call michael b jordan and say
congratulations on uh becoming one of
the people's
sexiest man alive i did not
call him i didn't call him i don't
i mean i'm i don't know like
he didn't do much he's just kind of sexy
i mean i guess he goes to the gym a lot
i guess i could congratulate him
i should congratulate his trainer really
um
it's more of an accomplishment for him
no
mike and i of course keep in touch
during this time and and we've sent each
other love but i
i have not congratulated him
specifically on that no
and what does it mean for you to be an
executive producer what was it so
important for you to be so hands-on
on this project because your character
is so important because she wants to
make movement she wants to go forward
with her independence well you know i i
love producing i love
problem solving and the truth is there
are certain stories that
just might not be made otherwise and and
certainly you know silly
love was one where people unfortunately
thought that there wasn't necessarily
a a market or an audience for a young
black love story
and i think when you know when people
tell me that there isn't an audience for
our stories it makes me
want to tell them even more so it felt
uh impactful for me to to try to get
this movie made
there's a lot of passion behind that you
really enjoyed this project didn't you
yeah i did i love i lo i love i
i don't do anything that i don't love
and i feel really privileged that i'm in
a position where i can do that certainly
earlier in my career there were things i
kind of
had to do as i was trying to find my way
in and now i feel really lucky that i
get to do things that i really burn for
and certainly
this was one of them a lot of your fans
were excited that i was talking to you
because a lot of people want to know
what's happening in the mcu world
and have you talked to natalie portman
are you filming
what is happening yeah natalie and i are
good friends so we talk a lot she's been
in
in in australia for a couple months
getting ready
training um which is really exciting so
she's there taika's there
uh he we've been sending text messages
back and forth he updates me on how
stuff is going with production
uh chris is getting you know i don't
know that he ever got out of shape he is
just
always kind of in shape but he's getting
ready um we're really excited we start
shooting you know luckily
um australia really has it together in
terms of keeping people safe there so
we're able to shoot at the top of next
year
you're absolutely beautiful this film is
absolutely beautiful i can't wait for
everyone to see it so
thank you for chatting with me really
appreciate it thank you so much for
having me appreciate you
bye
you